a prominent author named Andrea Bartz
reignited a familiar conversation over
the weekend when she tweeted about the
joys of being quote child-free here's
what her post said Child free people
will never experience the joy of
watching their child touch grass for the
first time and she responds to that by
saying okay but do parents know the joy
of being 37 and sleeping in and drinking
coffee in silence then leaving the house
on a moment's notice whenever the f I
want now the first and most obvious uh
response to this kind of claim is that
it's simply untrue it's a false premise
parents can and do know what it's like
to do all of those things sleep in drink
coffee peacefully Etc we know because we
experience those things before we had
kids and once our kids get older we'll
have just as much access to them as
Andrea Bartz does